January 20th 2012 the New Zealand Police
uses their anti-terrorism special
tactics group to conduct a raid
an illegal rate of a 32 million mansion
with 76 officers and two helicopters
reason a special request from the FBI
Target kim.com an apparent International
terrorist the police wouldn't not only
arrest camera but also sees 18 luxury
cars 175 million dollars in cash and 64
of his bank accounts this wasn't just
some random off the cuff rate either New
Zealand Security Bureau had been
stalking Kim for weeks before the raid
but those few weeks were nothing rumors
started flying around that the prime
minister of New Zealand John Key was an
on the plan for years
apparently the only reason he granted
Kim residency in the first place was so
that he could one day raid and extradite
Kim it wasn't just New Zealand's PM that
was taking heat either U.S president
Barack Obama had allegedly been
colluding with Hollywood the entire time
to orchestrate the entire plan what did
Kim do that was so vile and
apprehensible well he was the infamous
founder of a piracy site mega upload and
later mega.nz during its Heyday mega
upload had more than 150 million
registered users 50 million daily
visitors and it accounted for four
percent of the entire internet's total
traffic as such mega upload had lost
copyright holders more than 500 million
dollars making Kim an international
fugitive wanted for copyright
infringement money laundering
racketeering and wire fraud unlike the
pirate-based founders though Kim wasn't
running mega upload out of principle he
was running Mega upon load it as a
business and a very lucrative one at
that he had a net worth of at least 200
million dollars and he wasn't gonna go
down without a fight over the next
several years he would wage one of the
most expensive Court battles in New
Zealand history and come out rather
Victorious he would get New Zealand to
admit that they were illegally spying on
him that the raid used excessive force
and that the seizure of his property was
unjust and to this day 11 years later
kim.com is still a free man in New
Zealand that has yet to be extradited so
here's the insane story of mega upload
founder kim.com the internet Legend
that's classified as a terrorist
taking a look back the story of Kim
dates back to January 21st 1974. his
real name is Kim Schmitz and he was born
to an ordinary family in Kiel West
Germany but nothing about Kim was
ordinary in fact he was a troublemaker
from very early on as he had an interest
in hacking and when I say hacking I
don't mean Webkinz hacking I mean Mr
Robot type hacking in his teens Kim
claims to have hacked hundreds of U.S
companies including the likes of NASA
the Pentagon and Citibank apparently he
would hack into their PBX systems which
were wide open doors for him he would
then turn around and sell the access
codes to these systems for 200 a piece
Kim would even boast about his hacking
skills on German TV but to be honest I
don't think selling access codes to the
Pentagon for only 200 is something to
brag about I mean the real person
getting robbed there is him but I
digress us aside from selling these
access codes Kim would also sell
encrypted phones that couldn't be tapped
like lead to some pretty shady figures
but somehow neither of these landed came
in any trouble something that did land
him in trouble though was yet another
scheme with calling cards Kim would buy
stolen calling cards from American
hackers for cheap and then sell them for
full price in Hong Kong and the
Caribbean this made him a core 61 000
Euros in his teens but it also landed
him in jail in March of 1994. this would
result in 11 counts of Computer Fraud at
10 counts of data Espionage and several
other charges as well normally this
would land someone in jail for several
months if not over a year but given
Kim's age the judge would go easy on him
he would give him a two-year suspended
sentence which means that Kim didn't
have to go to jail but if you broke the
law again within the next two years he
would have to serve time for the
original crimes and the new crime Kim
had escaped jail time I'm with the skin
of his teeth but his life was basically
ruined I mean he literally had a
criminal record by the time he was 20
making him virtually unhirable or at
least that would be the case for most
people Kim however wore his criminal
record as a badge of honor from his
perspective being wanted by the police
at such a young age was simply a
testament to how good his hacking skills
were in fact he would use this
reputation to open a cyber security
Consulting business called Data protect
and one of his first clients was
Lufthansa airlines Kim likes to claim
that he dazzled Lufthansa with his
hacking skills other sources claimed
that he knew an Insider but either way
Kim was soon pulling in millions and his
lifestyle would reflect this he would of
course buy supercars Mansions yawns and
all the other regular stuff but he also
spent a bunch of money on creating an
online Persona you could say that Kim
was the first Instagram flexor in the
world
Kim was definitely not the most humble
guy out there which made one thing clear
he was no longer the nerd hacker he was
now the ridge hacker
now that Kim had a somewhat legitimate
I.T business you would think that he
would play it safe and stay out of
trouble but that just wasn't Kim's style
pretty soon he would be caught up in a
pump and dumps game with a company
called let's buy it.com let's buy it
with basically a wannabe Amazon back in
the.com days after.com funding dried up
though the company would soon be on the
verge of bankruptcy instead of letting
the company go bankrupt though Kim would
go ahead and invest 375 000 Euros into
the company in 2001. on top of this he
would claim that he was going to bring
on investors with 50 million euros and
that they were going to Stage a
turnaround this would of course cause
the stock to go wild but the turnaround
nor the 50 million ever came the only
thing that happened was Kim would walk
away with a 1.5 million euro profit from
the pump this wasn't the only scheme
that Kim pulled off either he would also
launch fintech companies called the
monkey Ag and monkey Bank to be honest
I'm not really sure what these companies
even did but what we do know is that Kim
would embezzle a few hundred thousand
Euros from them which made him a prime
target for the police fearful about its
freedom Kim would flee to Thailand and
Stage a massive publicity stunt he would
claim that he hacked into Mr
smallbeard's Sudanese bank account he
would also put up prize money of 10
million dollars for any information
regarding Mr smallbeard's capture but
this publicity stunt didn't exactly win
him much support and so he would just
turn to faking his death online
unfortunately this too didn't work and
Kim would soon be deported back to
Germany and put in jail in November of
2003. this time he would spend five
months in jail awaiting his trial before
getting off with another slap on the
wrist yet another suspended sentence of
20 months Kim became convinced that what
was holding him back was Germany what he
needed it was a change in scenery and
with that he would move to Hong Kong in
2003 to continue his his Shady
activities he would open up a new
business called trendox that was
apparently supposed to use AI to
generate unbelievable returns of 25 per
year that was complete BS in fact the
250 000 that Kim did spend on the
business mostly went towards design and
theatrics as opposed to creating an AI
system that actually worked little to
say no one signed up in fact the company
never even got permission to accept
investor funds so it was a complete
failure but while his real-life Fortune
was crumbling Kim would continue keeping
up his online persona for example he
would produce a couple of bizarre
animations that poked fun at Bill Gates
in a Flash animation called it Kimbo
special agent for example he would break
into Bill Gates house and write the
words Linux on his walls in another film
called The kimbogos Monaco Kim would go
on vacation only to constantly catch
Bill Gates trying to spy on him this was
mostly just satire at the time but this
has ended up being surprisingly accurate
but while these films got Kim some
internet points the truth was that his
real life was quickly falling apart in
fact he had stooped so low that he was
going to airports just so that he could
take pictures in parked airplanes
clearly he was desperate and this
desperateness would transform him from
being a rich hacker to being a criminal
hacker
foreign
five Kim wood officially change his name
from Kim Schmitz to kim.com and this
marked the beginning of his piracy days
he would change the name of his IT
company data protect to mega upload and
Atlanta websites entered around file
sharing honestly he was pretty early to
the whole file sharing thing so he could
have easily created a legitimate file
sharing platform like Dropbox which was
created two years after mega upload I
mean technically if you ask Kim or
especially any of his lawyers they'll
assure you that Mega uploaded is indeed
a legitimate file sharing platform that
has no intention of breaking copyright
regulation but you can take that for
what you will whether it was intentional
or not mega upload would become one of
the largest piracy sites in the world
only beaten out by the likes of the
Pirate Bay no one knew that it was
actually kim.com behind this company
though you see it Kim had registered the
business under an Elias called it Kim
Timmy Jim Vester in Finland so as far as
the public was concerned it was run by
some random Finnish dude but while camo
wasn't getting any of the credit or
notoriety for creating mega upload he
was definitely getting the cash the
company was pulling in hundreds of
millions of dollars most of which ended
up with Kim as he owned 68 of the
business he finally had the money that
he always claimed he did and he would
use this Fortune to buy his way into New
Zealand you see it by purchasing 10 and
million dollars worth of New Zealand
government bonds he would get himself
placed into the high investment category
of immigration and once he was in he
would purchase a 24 million mansion just
outside Auckland but the truth was that
neither New Zealand nor his neighbors
were happy to have him and Kim's efforts
to joke about his past with his
neighbors just made him look worse in
fact he sent letters to his neighbors
with the following first of all let me
assure you that having a criminal
neighbor like me comes with benefits our
newly opened local money laundering
facility can help you with your tax
product optimization our network of
international insiders can provide you
with the valuable stock tips let's just
say his neighbors didn't find this humor
to be very funny but while New Zealand
wasn't a fan of Kim the internet very
much was and when it was revealed that
he was the one behind the mega upload in
2011. he cemented himself as an internet
Legend he would go on to expand the mega
Empire by launching Mega video Mega
picks Mega Live Mega pay and so on and
so forth but as far as the FBI was
concerned all of this was just a mega
fraud as such on January 5th 2012
indictments would be filed against Kim
for racketeering copyright infringement
and money laundering and two weeks later
New Zealand's anti-terrorist Squad would
descend upon Kim's mega mansion and shot
down mega upload
foreign
after the raid it Kim would be thrown
into prison at Mount Eden where he spent
a month before being released on bail he
didn't have much to return to though his
wife were divorced him shortly after and
that mega upload was completely shut
down
not to mention much of his property
other than his Mansion had been seized
by the police but despite the oblique
situation Kim would fight back
his first goal was to take down the New
Zealand authorities because without
their help the FBI couldn't really do
much fortunately for Kim this wasn't too
hard as the authorities had broken a lot
of protocol due to pressure from the FBI
for one they had been illegally spying
on him for weeks two they literally came
in with an anti-terrorist Squad three
they unnecessarily seized his property
and before they turned over this
illegally seized data over to the FBI
Kim's lawyers would retaliate through
all four of these bases and more or less
humiliate the authorities for this raid
after about five years of this New
Zealand would back off and simply agreed
to settle with Kim for an undisclosed
amount the FBI on the other hand was not
looking to settle by any means
they were looking to extradite Camp to
the US and charge him with every
copyright law they could think of but
this requires going through a pretty
lengthy and often dead-end extradition
process which the FBI is still dealing
with to this day will he ever be
extradited well only time will tell
in the meantime though Kim went ahead
and launched yet another fall sharing
platform called mega.nz with a couple of
co-founders and to really rub it into
the faces of authorities Kim would
launch the site exactly one year after
mega upload was shut down and to be
honest mega.nz is a pirate's dream
unlike torrents which use a peer-to-peer
Network Mega uses a server client
Network which makes it substantially
harder to identify Pirates also
everything is end to end encrypted which
again it just makes it even harder
little to say mega was a massive success
within the first hour of launch they
would attract a hundred thousand users
within a few days this would grow to a
million users and within a few years
this would grow to 35 million users
today NECA has over 200 million users
and stores 107 billion files now with
all of that being said I do want to note
that Kim is no longer involved in mega
and the mega is very much trying to move
away from this association with piracy
they're more than happy to take down
copyrighted material from their platform
as they truly want to be seen as a
competitor to Dropbox Google Drive
iCloud and OneDrive but why wish them
the best of luck in this transition the
reality is that a lot of pirates still
use Mega in fact there used to be a
full-on subreddit called it megalinx
with over 30 000 links after Reddit took
down the subreddit the community just
moved on to other social media platforms
and even their own dedicated websites so
Mega definitely still has quite a bit of
work to do and hopefully they're able to
but in the meantime James initial
presence is still very much weighing
down the brand
since leaving Mega Kim has experimented
with some outlandish things like
experimenting with politics he created a
political party called it the internet
party but this didn't really go anywhere
in fact the party only won 499 votes in
total in the 2017 election there was
also rumors that he was going to launch
his own cryptocurrency but that never
came to fruition either nowadays it
seems like Kim has just been sitting at
home gaming and enjoying the remains of
his fortune while his lawyers work to
prevent extradition and to be honest
that doesn't sound that bad at all I
should also mention that he is actually
really good at gaming in fact he was the
number one at Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 3 player in the entire world
before the police raid so maybe he
should try his hand at streaming but
then again maybe it's better that he
just continued laying low as at the end
of the day he has indeed the internet
Legend that's classified as a terrorist
do you think Kim belongs in jail comment
that down below also drop a like if
you'd like to see more video videos
about internet Legends and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community suggest for the video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one